اجتماع اوروبي خارج حدود اوروبا العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كيف تستقبل على اراضيها وزراء
خارجيه دول الاتحاد الاوروبي في اجتماع
تصفه كياف التي تطمح للانضمام الى الاتحاد
بالمحطه التاريخيه وهو طموح يعبر عنه وزير
الخارجيه الاوكراني بلغه فيها الكثير من
الثقه هذا حدث تاريخي لانه لاول مره على
الاطلاق سيجتمع مجلس الشؤون الخارجيه خارج
حدوده الحاليه حدود الاتحاد الاوروبي ولكن
داخل الحدود المستقبليه للاتحاد الاوروبي
وزيره الخارجيه الفرنسيه
وجهت رساله الى روسيا مؤكده ان عزم دول
الاتحاد لن يضعف ابدا
اوكرانيا بالنسبه الينا عضوا في العائله
الاوروبيه سنرافقها على هذا الطريق الذي
يقودها نحو اوروبا بغض النظر عن الرمزيه
هذا تعبير عن دعمنا الثابت والدائم لها
الى ان تحقق النصر
الرئيس الاوكراني فولودي ميرسي يضغط منذ
الغزو الروسي لبلاده على دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي على جبهتين الحصول على مزيد من
الاسلحه والدبابات والصواريخ خاصه في ظل
الهجوم المضاده التي تقوده بلاده وعلى
تسريع انضمام كياف الى الاتحاد الاوروبي